June 2014 Islamic state forces
celebrating after astonishing the world
sweeping from Syria through northern
Iraq to Mosul ahead of them the Iraqi
army had simply fled terrified by the
reputation for ultra violence that is
had carefully cultivated when they
marched on Mosul the members of the
Iraqi army who were there who saw them
coming quite simply weren't prepared to
be captured they knew if they were
caught what would happen and so those
soldiers lay down their arms and fled
and abandoned the city and weren't
prepared to fight in Mosul's historic
mosque is leader Abu Bakr al-baghdadi
declared a new Islamic caliphate making
Islamic state different to any jihadi
group that had come before that
linguistic and symbolic messaging from
the group was hugely important in
mobilizing what we then saw which was
tens of thousands of people's entire
families for more than 90 countries
across the world getting up migrating
travelling there to be part of this
project is pioneered propaganda and a
new brand of extreme violence carried
out on foreign hostages james foley
steven sotloff david haines alan henning
peter kassig kenji goto all brutally
murdered their killings broadcast on the
internet isis came along and set a new
threshold for atrocities it aped and
built on what we already seen al-qaeda
do but it took it to the next step the
next group that will come along be at
Isis its next evolution or someone else
is going to have to beat that in some
ways in some new horror and new misery
to be able to capture attention and get
their message across
[Music]
Lamech State wanted to lure the West
onto its own territory for a decisive
battle it goaded European nations with a
series of devastating attacks like those
in Paris at the batter clan and in
Brussels the West responded taking the
battle to Islamic state strongholds with
allies on the ground today you know
we're gonna fight every day in Iraq
Kurdish Shia and Army forces circled
Mosul a protracted air and ground
campaign finally prevailed but only by
destroying much of the city and much of
its civilian population and the group's
Syrian headquarters in Raqqa finally
fell - in the city square where so many
had been executed
jubilant Kurdish troops could celebrate
its recapture cleared now from its last
pockets of resistance Islamic state has
been forced underground but analysts
warn it is far from finished we're not
dealing with a young organization with
no experience we're dealing with an
organization that has been defeated
before and come back to be the most
successful terrorist organization the
world has ever seen this is what is
leaves behind untold devastation and
incalculable human misery its caliphate
lies in ruins but its ideology lives on
and many of its devotees have survived
slipping back into the shadows to fight
another day
Domenic Waghorn Sky News